when you get finished with those jeans
and decide you don't like them giving me
i'm going to make two pairs
barbra
let me just tell you something sarah
haynes and uh jill biden wore that dress
already on tv anna navarro has whoopi
goldberg's back the political
commentator came to her co-host defense
on the view thursday after shark tank
star barbara corcoran made a joke about
whoopi's weight the fallout came as the
view host and barbarous fellow shark
tank judges mark cuban and damon john
were discussing emma greed who is the
ceo of denim brand good american a
company she co-founded with khloe
kardashian and someone who is set to be
the first black woman guest shark on the
show panelist sunny hostin had kind
words for emma saying she loves the
jeans and even recommends them to her
fellow co-hosts and as sonny continued
praising the brand whoopi took interest
will they fit this covenant yes okay yes
they will
that's what i would ask they fit this
copic and when you get finished with
those jeans and decide you don't like
them give me i'm going to make two pairs
barbara barbara's comment didn't sit
well with anna who quickly clapped back
at the entrepreneur for her fat shaming
joke
let me just tell you something sarah
haynes and
jill biden wore that dress already on tv
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and anna is right donald trump jr did
try that on her i was flabbergasted and
frankly my first thought was oh my god
just last month anna directly addressed
the son of former president trump who
called out her weight on twitter after
anna falsely tested positive for coven
19. donald jr wrote
given the anna navarro news i think it's
time for a national conversation about
the dangers of covet 19 and obesity on
air anna reminded the former first son
that she pokes fun at her way every day
and acknowledges she struggles with her
weight she then became the clapback
queen i know that when you are a dimwit
with no skill or talent or significant
accomplishments living off your father's
fame and name and fortune
you've got to draw attention to yourself
but baby if you want to have a
conversation about colvin and obesity
you could have had it last october when
your elderly obese father had
get them man it
got the goal
to pick on me the ladies of the view are
currently in their 25th season just last
month e.t visited the set to chat with
the co-host they reflected on the
milestone season and why they love what
they do oh it's much more fun to have
fewer people i think because you can
talk more and you know more people can
yeah we can say more to each other even
it became like i've got i gotta get a
word in here now you know it was i don't
i don't love that but we've learned how
to do that now um but the opposite of
that was being alone in your house which
is what we were for the past two years
and now as we would be like well what do
you think and then all of a sudden i
have to give a speech i didn't love that
i didn't love that i like the audience i
like the camaraderie i like the fun of
it which is what this is about now we're
doing what we're supposed to be doing
this is our this is our gig and this is
you know
our our uh
our gift from the world because not
everybody gets to have an opinion not
everybody gets to say this is what i
think and here's why and let's talk
about this this is a really great job
it's a really great job and i'm going to
speak for us but i think we're lucky as
hell